thank you for doing this interview
you know that i've been a fan of your
work for a very long time
and i finally managed to convince you to
do an interview with me
it's taken 17 years and six weeks
well thank you for having me stephen um
so if you could do
a poster for any band
any tv series any movie you don't have
to worry about likeness rights
you don't have to worry about the rights
you just get to do it
what's the thing that you would love to
do
yeah what's the thing um there's a lot
of them
nowadays i mean early on i wouldn't have
expected that to run into these issues
but now things like escape from new york
uh predator
commando you realize that how many
likenesses are involved
and and they're just really impossible
so then of course the more
harder it is to do them the more you're
like i really wish
i could do escape from new york with all
the likenesses because
that's really hard right now i know you
can do them with snakes likeness but
um so those are kind of the great white
whales that uh would be
a lot of fun to do and uh tv shows yeah
i don't know
no i i i completely get it um i think
for fans of you
for your of your work i think they're
curious how long does it actually take
you
to do a poster could you sort of talk
about a time frame
so i come from doing like gig posters
and a lot of times early on it was just
like you have a week to do this and so
or less
two days we need a poster and so that
was always kind of the driving force
behind how i started my um process was
just deadlines
and so in the early days of doing stuff
like mondo and stuff we would do like
you know like iron man 2 would be done
like in a week
and uh and because they were just like
we need it and so you have to do it
right now
and that was a lot of fun and nowadays
people are more like you can take as
long as you want
which really means that i start working
on all these other projects
between them so i have you know people
that are hitting me up for different
things you know i'm
doing stuff for friends they're like
stickers or shirts or whatever
and so then you're just putting off a
poster putting off a poster
like mad max fury road we're working on
that for a screening for uh
um yeah ken harm and now i'm forgetting
uh he just emailed me they're down in
california
i didn't even know that did i know that
you were doing a mad max fury road
poster
yeah i'm not sure it was it was
announced right before the quilted thing
and then they were like this the roxy
was going to do a screening with
spoke art obviously and ken at spokart
it was very exciting and we were like
a month away from it's happening now i
mean
people were they were selling like
screening tickets and stuff and then
um the roxy obviously had to shut
everything down which was a huge bummer
and so then they just postponed it and
now they're you know
there's rumblings that it's starting up
again and so anyway all that to say is
that when it was happening i was like
all right this is 100 what i'm working
on you know i'm
50 60 and all of a sudden they're like
we're postponing it so then you just
kind of like well
i guess i'll move on to something else
and so i have what i like it's a fun
poster but i need to get back and now
they're like okay now there's a deadline
again
so um it really deadlines are huge i
mean like star wars when i did those it
was like a month per poster
because they were like take as much as
you want in time so then you're just
doing it over and over and over and
making it the best
it can be um whereas like uh the thing
or
those early on posters it was usually
like a couple weeks
and so so yeah that's so interesting now
i also would like to see um
i think secretly you should be showing
us a work in progress
of mad max fury road on camera right now
because i know it's right next to you
right here you're right exactly it's
amazing
um what uh what's the fastest poster
that you've done
and which is the one that took the
longest
yeah that's a good question i i think
with theory error i don't hear that uh
iron man 2 which i mentioned that
probably was kind of the biggest turn
and burn type thing
um i know akira was one of the biggest
fastest print jobs we ever did i think
the screening was like on a friday or
saturday
and i turned the files into our printer
like on a
wednesday or thursday it was crazy he
like printed it all one day
and then next date it and so that was a
big turnaround and then the longest
uh
well uh let's see captain america civil
war
took over a year to get approved so i'd
done it and then they're like oh we're
running in some rights issues and it
actually took a year to get it
completely approved
over a year and so that was a huge like
eye opener for me as a as a freelancer
that does this
supposedly for a living i guess um to be
like all right
i just did a job and they'll be like
okay we'll pay you in a year
so it was fine it worked out great um
but it was just uh
it really helped it made me think i need
to do little things like these like
sticker sales and other like uh
um side projects that kind of bring in
revenue while we're waiting for
approvals
what do you do with your original
drawings so my posters are usually
pretty
big and collagey and so there isn't
necessarily and i won't say necessary
there isn't a big master sheet usually
of just
one poster that has everything on it so
it's all sketchbooks and sketch pads and
some of it's even digital stuff
nowadays um so i need to really
because i'm like sarah's like oh you
should put out a book and so i'm like i
need to track down
and really put this stuff all together
but
right now it's just all over the place
i've given some stuff away i don't
really like to sell it just because i
might eventually do a book and so then
you're like holding on to it and i'm
probably a little bit of a hoarder that
way
um but yeah so i don't really do
anything with them
i was going to say there there is
obviously a huge market
for originals and i was going to say
that like and
again i don't really know how long it
takes but let me use sean of the dead
for example
if you if you had you if you made a
shawn of the dead and you hand
did it and said this is my sketch right
of course sean
that that's a lot of money right yeah it
definitely would be it just
is really hard for me to go back and uh
and revisit things and be like it's done
it's perfect as it is of course i'll go
i'll go back and like mine it for
sticker ideas and stuff so i guess i'm a
bit of a
hypocrite but um i need to get better at
that stuff or train my kids to do it
just be like all right kids you know
let's put this all together
start drawing and do a little factory
but uh
yeah i don't really take advantage of
things as much as i should
so hopefully my wife doesn't watch this
video she's gonna get all these ideas
of jumping into actually why i get to
talk to you so you are doing the
halloween poster
which is the main reason why we're
talking um talk a little bit about where
this
this whole thing came from and is there
any because
halloween is one of those properties
that a number of people have tackled
is there more pressure you put more
pressure on yourself
on that kind of a poster where other
artists have interpreted it
um or is it sort of like um
you know or is it just another post yeah
that's a good question
i it came about with uh mike from gray
matter who i've known for a long time he
said hey we have the rights to this and
i'm a huge uh john carpenter he's
probably kind of my
perfect director a certain body of his
work is just like
everything was a hit i mean my goal is
kind of like to do everything that i
really like of his
so i don't know if we'll be doing like
invisible man but making our way through
a select portion of his filmography and
last halloween i was like okay we're
going to do that
and then things just didn't work out and
so now i'm catching up on
last halloween's project which is why we
have a halloween poster coming out in
april so really the um
do you usually prefer the regular
edition or the variant
on posters i uh i always try to prefer
or put my favorite as the regular
edition just because it's the one that
gets printed the most
and it would kind of drive uh me
personally crazy if uh i was printing
the most
of uh not an inferior but my lesser
favorite one so
it's like oh unless you're really
printing a ton of metallics and being
like this is the best but
it's just not affordable so that's why
it's a variant but most of the time i
try to make the
regular kind of the best at least my
favorite and then the variant is
something that kind of
especially with my variants having a lot
of gold metallics they have kind of
become a little bit of a series of their
own so it's like gold metallics and
silvers and grays
you can put them all up and a lot of
them would really go together and so
then that becomes its own thing but as a
whole i don't look at any one variant
say
that one you know is my favorite over
the regular over time there will be ones
i look back at like when we did
uh the first avengers poster i really
liked
the regular and then the variant was the
more monochromatic
grays and reds and over time i actually
much prefer that variant because i think
it just looks cooler
and the the regular has you know too
many colors in my opinion so
um that just really it changes over time
but i try to
pick the best one as being the regular
edition and the variant becomes
is it's just kind of a second like this
is your second choice kind of thing
i i i really like your uh halloween
poster
but i will say that i really i think the
regular is my favorite the
use of the use of orange is just really
cool awesome
awesome yeah that's what i think too the
gold is cool because it's part of my
you know variants of all having gold but
obviously orange is like you know orange
pumpkins orange halloween
so i think that's uh that was a lot of
fun just to color that one so
uh you recently did a terminator poster
and you
you did a timed edition on it when you
did that honestly what were you like
really hoping to sell versus how many
you actually sold
i was hoping to sell a thousand which is
you know still
uh big numbers for me because most of my
runs are usually like
700 um for a regular edition
and so a thousand would be cool um
and that's why we didn't do it for a
huge window we didn't be like here it's
pre-selling for a week because then we
were worried i mean it's just
sarah and i are the ones kind of running
the show here and so we didn't want to
be
shipping more than we could handle
and so it actually was more than a
thousand but it still worked out it was
stressful i guess but yeah it was it was
it was a surprise
it was a surprise i would imagine that
there there's an element of this is
amazing i can't believe you sold this
many and then at the same time you're
like oh my god this is going to be a ton
of work to ship
right right yeah it was uh it was
ridiculous we were shipping for like
two months or something and my wife is
hiring all of my daughter who's 16
all of her friends so they were coming
and there was this huge packing and they
were just looking at me like what do you
do for a living you know here's a movie
we've never
seen and we're folding it up and sarah's
like
you know she wasn't having them roll
anything of course because just
you know it's it's actually kind of a
little bit of an art should roll a
poster and so she had to do all the
the rolling or i did and so it was a
it was an experience i don't know if
we'll be doing it you know monthly but
right
that's actually something i wanted to
ask you about you you're very popular
poster artist and i'm curious if you in
in your mind within talking to sarah are
you leaning towards in the future
wanting to do more timed editions so
more people can actually get your poster
because i think one of the issues is
when you release certain things they
sell out very quickly
and what's that line of okay let's do a
timed edition
so more people can get it versus you
know
we're only going to make 600 or 800 or
500.
yeah it's i mean as you said that time
was our first one and i think it was
it was kind of an experiment to see how
it went and there were certain aspects
of it we really
enjoyed and certain aspects so you kind
of miss the old ways of being like this
is a fun event that's more limited
it still ended up being i guess somewhat
limited i mean there is a finite number
of that addition but it's just bigger
and you don't you just don't want to
make things you don't want to give the
impression you're just kind of churning
stuff out
just to meet i mean just to have it just
be such a huge thing
you don't want to take advantage of a
collector base and just be like we're
really going to try to
to fleece people or anything so there's
a bunch of variant uh
variables that we kind of try to try to
think about it's just like you're kind
of gut feeling like i feel good about
this and so
i feel like if you do one timed edition
of a year
then um the other stuff you kind of do
your own thing with
the regular going back to the regular
edition type stuff but whether or not we
do more than one movie poster a year i
don't know i mean it would be fun
it's just um making it work out so this
year we might do two i guess if mad max
berry road and halloween works out and
then
who knows maybe we'll really do a bunch
but
have you guys ever talked about and i
don't know if this is possible or not
but for some of your older posters
has there ever been a discussion of like
um doing
another variant of an older poster
uh for whatever reason so it's like you
know um you know making like a third
variant
or doing something like that or does
that sort of never come up
yeah well um so like reprinting
something you might say
yeah yeah yeah i
i mean i've been doing gig posters now
for i guess over 20 years
which is you know looking at me you
wouldn't know it you'd think i was
15 so uh but anyway
um so yeah i there there's a lot of
taboos in the poster world
and reprints used to be a big one of
them
and i don't know if it is anymore maybe
people are doing it but it used to be
like
you just made something that you
considered part of you know your work
and you didn't go back and touch it you
try not to go back and mess with it and
again with stickers i'll sometimes do a
pulling element from an older poster and
do is it's a sticker or something
but uh reprinting an entire poster it's
almost like you feel like you have to
get permission
from every single person who bought that
first run
and make sure they were okay with it
because
it used to be and again i don't know if
it still is you're kind of lowering the
um collectibility of posters that
they've really cherished
not that we're all about you know things
going up in value and all sort of stuff
but you have to respect the fact that
some of these people paid money for
these on the secondary market
and you don't want to be like now here's
the third variance and then they're like
oh and now
here's the fourth and it's not that much
different colors and stuff so
that that's something we do consider and
also of course a lot of these
uh we would run into rights issues where
i couldn't reprint anything
that i'd done for mondo as a poster
without
going back to mondo and say hey let's
work something out and i think that
might kind of go against their
credo of reprinting older stuff as well
so it would be
it'd be a lot of work just to make sure
nobody's feelings got hurt
or you weren't kind of doing something
that seemed
gross i mean if i was like dead or on my
deathbed and they're like let's do a
fundraiser so let's raise you know do a
reprint of the thing then people would
probably like rally together
and he'd show a picture of me in the
hospital like oh thank you
but uh probably until then we probably
won't be doing too many reprints
i mean i don't know so i don't think so
we don't have any plans just because it
would be pretty uh
if you're pretty taboo i guess no i
completely get it i was just curious um
one of the things is that uh there was a
little bit of a phase
where there was a lot of metal posters
being done and
you have released a number of metal
posters but it seems like in the last
year or two i don't know the exact time
frame
that no one's really doing metal posters
anymore and
is it um is there a reason for this what
were your thoughts on metal posters
because i
i have one of your metal posters on my
wall the drive poster
yeah that's [ __ ] cool so you know
like i
sort of i'm saying this it's like a fan
like i kind of want more
uh even though they're really hard to
get and so anyway i'm just curious
yeah yeah that's a great question it's
i mean there's a bunch of factors i know
um
like you had discussed yesterday just on
the phone we talked about you
mentioned you probably thought one of
the reasons is it's just our people
buying them as much and it does cost a
lot so like a regular post might be 65
bucks a metal poster might be 350 or
something crazy
um i think another factor is just uh
the screens print shop that printed a
lot of them dnl like i was talking to
steve the guy who ran that
and he said um like
it's like printing kind of like a stop
sign where you're using pretty different
inks than post drinks and a lot of stuff
can get really toxic
so they're all wearing like breathers
and doing stuff that's a lot
heavier duty than just poster ink so
they won't they're like
we really have to shut down the shop
when we're printing metal posters
because
it's such a it is a big deal it's a big
process
and so that would be a trick just making
sure you were printing it in a safe way
that
we didn't know about you know 10 15
years ago
and then it comes out a lot of this
stuff is a little more
i mean i don't think they're bad to own
because i own like i own a lot of my
metal posters and hopefully you're not
breathing in like stuff now but i think
it's just the printing process like
i know it's obviously not water-based
ink so it's like
oil-based ink and you're just breathing
in some stuff that
makes these uh metal posters just
they're they're they're more work to
print than a
regular one what about like wood
editions because for example like
you know you have the django uh
unchained um
there's been a number of wood posters
that people have done are those easier
to make
i think so yeah i would definitely
assume you could use water-based ink on
those and i think those would be a lot
easier so that probably just comes down
to
collectibility like are people really
interested in wood posters and
and even with metal you have to think
well where
um is there an angle like a terminator
poster would have been a perfect
poster to do metal on obviously and that
one um we were just like uh
we'll do kind of a metal paper for the
variant but we didn't do a metal poster
um
but in django was perfect on wood i
think just because it was from that era
so with halloween you're kind of like
well what is the angle to print it on a
metal or a wood
you know is there a connection and i
don't think we we
didn't consider those type of um
materials to print on to always because
we were like
there isn't really anything other than
paper you know paper bags for candy and
stuff like that so
when you make a poster how many do you
typically save for yourself i've noticed
over the years you do a lot of cool
things for charity
you're raising money for really great
causes
which i just want to say thank you for
doing that but
it's like amazing to me to be like okay
so all of a sudden out of the blue
there's a kill bill poster
or there is a you know you whip out
something that's
older to raise money again awesome but
it's like there's only so many of these
you can probably have
in your collection so i'm just curious
how many you typically
save of the things you make and do you
still have
like more than one robocop poster left
or are you just like you just have one
right yeah yeah i think um early on i
didn't realize
these things would be at all
collectibles so like lost boys
i did that one and i kept one poster and
so for many years i'm like this is my
lost voice poster and it's one poster in
the file
and of course it goes back into the flat
file and i put other posters and it gets
all smashed so i have one smashed lost
voice poster
um and then later on somebody else felt
sorry for me was like you only have one
so they sent me another one which was
really nice
i think i might have traded for i can't
remember but anyway so now i have two
lost ones monsters
but other ones um since then i've been
like okay i need to keep more of these
so then early on which
now we probably maybe it's a good idea
because i have like
50 000 flat files in here we started
keeping 10 of the regulars
10 of the aps 10 of the regular variants
and 10 of those so it's
20 of each poster and so it's a good
amount especially since i got a ton of
kids
um that are supposedly going to
potentially want one of these i'm sure
they won't you're like
every one of my child children will want
every single one of my posters
i'm like they're not gonna they're gonna
be like out of all the thousands of
posters you've done we're gonna want
like one
so but that's where they come from is i
usually just try to keep
ten and ten and a lot of times with
posters it's like you have your big sale
so like with terminator and then we're
going to sell them we're shipping them
shipping
and then at the end you might be like
okay we kept x amount back for damages
and so we have those the last 10 or 15
or whatever
and you're gonna have those and sell
them once things quiet down
in case there aren't anything if people
say i have a damage then they're like
okay ship it back or destroy it
we'll ship your replacement but if you
still have some at the end of that whole
run
then you're like oh i can sell these now
but at the same time
you've moved on to other things and so
you're just having them in flat files
and so then you have stacks of these
weird posters where you're having this
is where all my terminator posters
and then you open another flat file and
you're like oh here's more flap
here's more terminator posters you know
so then you kind of are i can let's see
if i can turn my camera around
screw it up but let's see so you can see
my flat
files and let's see those
flat files right there and then i have
two rows
back there so anyway
you have one or two flat files i do yeah
yeah i used to have kind of an addiction
of collecting flat files on craigslist
but
now i switched to cigarettes so no i'm
just kidding
no it's gonna be like what so for
example like
for like a big trouble in little china
varied there's like
35 or 40 of those do you still have
10 variants or do you still have like if
you have like one or two of those
posters
yes that would be from the early era of
like oh
why keep them if you can sell them for
forty dollars back in the day and so
that's what we did we just sold them so
a lot of those blade runners
uh the thing big trouble little china
robocop you're keeping maybe five and
so i did sell a robocop i think this
last year for something
or two years ago and it was a big deal
because you're like i don't have i have
like five of these
and i have more than five kids so uh
it's gonna be an issue uh if every one
of them wants it they're gonna be going
on ebay or something but then sarah was
like
realistically your kids aren't gonna
want a robocop poster so
that was a nice a nice reminder the one
the one thing that i've always wanted
and i've never gotten uh because of
the price uh the robocop medal which is
one of those
posters that f i you know what i mean so
do you
so you have one of those or do you have
multiples
if i have more than one it would be two
but i certainly don't have more than two
i mean again so it's like your metal
posters then you put a piece of paper
metal poster piece of paper and then
uh your say drive comes in you're like
where do i keep these oh keep them in
the metal poster door and so then you
put them on and these things weigh
like considerable so to get to my
older ones like those you're like all
right let me just pull my back you know
so i would guess that i have probably
won i mean like
one or two of that robocop one just
because
it's so far under there i need to i mean
we're eventually probably gonna move
from this place and that's when you'll
like find all these old
old prints but yeah definitely not
enough that you could feel comfortable
selling it you
a lot of that stuff you're kind of like
well i could sell this poster for
whatever it was going for i don't know a
thousand dollars or something
and then later on or you can be like or
i could do
the same amount of work done just
working on like an art print and make
that thousand dollars on that
and so you're kind of like i'll just do
that instead it's easier and it's
something new
i try not to give the impression too
much of like kind of resting on my
laurels and
selling older stuff but occasionally
like a couple years ago our dog needed
like a ton of
veterinary bill stuff so then i was like
okay i gotta sell a bunch of stuff
because we immediately need this money
so
then we just did that and so you try to
kind of a good balance of putting out
new stuff and making your money off that
and letting the old stuff just kind of
live its own life and then occasionally
dipping into the old stuff
if you're trying to cover your your
ill-placed bets
i i completely get that um recently
a um justin used to be with mondo
sold off some of his collection and one
of which was a kill bill medal
which which is a very rare uh
metal edition are there a few
like really rare items that you have
that people might not even believe
are sort of in the ether like the kill
built metal
i had never seen before um when that
went up so are there other like metal
editions of some posters that we do not
know about as fans
i don't think so unless they're printing
stuff i mean there's always weird things
where i have some guardians of the
galaxy
stuff that's on different paper with
different colors it's kind of like oh
what about this paper with this
and then we're kind of like no no that
during the printing process those would
be kind of like uh
test print type stuff but nothing that
would be
to the uh the amount of work that would
take to make a metal one
it would have to be a real like that
would be a lot of money that they would
spend to print it and they usually only
spend money if they can make that back
through at least
publicity like that kill bill medal
where they're presenting it to tarantino
and uh and they kind of get their value
that they put into printing it
out of it that way by saying here's a
cool thing we printed even though we're
not selling any
so nothing that i know of in terms of
metal
um yeah i can't think of any i have a
big avengers age of ultron on metal
that i think they printed a couple of
those and that was a different printing
process so it wasn't screen printed and
uh
that thing again i don't know if you can
see just turn my camera so it's that guy
right there it's pretty big
so it's oversized and it's pretty cool
but i guess they just made two of them
that was hero complex
and uh so that was fun but they didn't
make any of those to sell i don't
think unless they sold their copy i
don't know um
do you one of the things i find
interesting about the poster market or
the poster
in posters in general is there seems to
be
like a lot of people are making and not
to criticize halloween because i'm super
happy you made it but a lot of people
make a halloween poster
right um but like there's not a lot of
orson welles posters or kubrick posters
or
the list goes on and on like there's no
caddyshack poster i mean i can give you
a list
of so many great movies that have never
had a poster
is there some reason for this or is is
it just
you know the rights issues like why is
it that certain movies have just never
been done
yeah i think some of the reasons you
mentioned are a perfect example reasons
like the rights issues
and then i think a lot of times we just
get stuck in this kind of uh
i want to say rut but it's like
everybody's doing their uh
escape from new york poster everybody's
doing their halloween poster everybody's
doing those
things that we just kind of keep going
back to that well and saying i really
like this poster there's an audience
because we sold a bunch
and so but i i totally agree i think we
should be expanding it and being like
well let's make a deep impact poster you
know let's start
oh i'm gonna stop you there come on now
if anything let's do armageddon yeah
yep yep um no no deep rising that's what
i meant deep rising
got it okay i accept that that's better
so um those type of things where i i
agree we need to be pushing that type of
uh
agenda where we're doing more posters
because you know every
every great film deserves a couple great
posters and uh
it's just people being uh kind of taking
that bull by the horns and saying we're
gonna go out and do this and track down
the rights
i mean a lot of these licensing things
that i get in the mail you'll get a
licensing catalog from a company
that licenses all these movies and it's
like you say you look through and you're
saying okay halloween
you know all these ones are are ones
that we've seen posters for over and
over
because those are the ones that whoever
owns them is like i'm going to put the
net out there and be like all licensed
to anyone that has money
and the people that whoever owns
caddyshack or whatever they're not
necessarily in there
they're not necessarily having the push
and at some point
maybe they'll be like you know what
there's money to be made here and then
they'll get involved these licensing
companies and all of a sudden you'll
see a bunch of like ghostbusters stuff
which i think that was the case a couple
years ago
probably now 10 years ago where all of a
sudden ghostbusters stuff was really
popping
up everywhere because they were realized
it was a lot of
a lot of money to be made i guess you
have a lot of posters
that have been killed for whatever
reason you know like you did
a lot of work on something and then all
of a sudden
everyone's like yeah we can't do this
you know so are there a lot of those
kinds of
rough posters that you have yeah not a
lot
um but there are a few that kind of made
it to a certain phase and then got
killed
um so it goes that way with gig
posters we were doing some stuff for
frank lloyd wright's you know falling
water house it was kind of like an
architectural print that one
got completely done and it got killed um
so i'll just have to turn that into some
weird airplane or something but
anyway um yeah there's been a few some
planet of the ape stuff that got killed
um that we saw later on mondo put it
printed it kind of in a cool art book of
like rejected things
so i wouldn't say there's like 20 but
there's probably
five to ten different ones in different
phases you know even that uh
fury road was kind of in that pile for a
while because it was half done and then
they were like
stop work on it we're not getting the
roxy's you know we're not having
screenings right now and now it's
restarting
up again so going back and kind of
blowing the dust off all that stuff and
seeing okay this is where we're at
hopefully not starting over we'll see a
joke online about your work has been
that you've done a jurassic park poster
have you ever done a jurassic park
poster i don't think so
nowadays people will show me posters and
be like hey remember this and i'm like i
have no
recollection of this so i'm like that
stephen king only there's no drugs
involved it's just age where you'll be
like i don't remember riding the tommy
knockers and
for me i don't think there was a
jurassic park area where i did that
but i get those emails all the time
especially around april first for some
reason
so i think people like playing jokes and
and that has been a dream and maybe even
at some point
with mondo there was a couple that was
like um
nightmare before christmas that was a
big one with her like we have the rights
to it start work on it
and so then you're kind of starting to
gear up and all of a sudden disney kind
of switched their whole
um all their rights changed overnight
and then that was one that was killed
where they're like okay don't work on it
anymore
and then people i think you might have
even announced it or there was a couple
ones that were announced
and then they just had to change and so
then people were like it got done but it
just wasn't released or it was printed
only a few people have it kind of a
thing
and so those kind of like urban legend
type things grow but
so you're telling me you did a nightmare
before christmas poster
no i didn't complete it so this was back
in the day
i think if i did it again now i'd have
to uh i'd have to start over so
we'll see it's really hard to look at
something from 10 years ago and be like
now i can pick up and start you know
you'll be like this looks terrible
but a lot of myself you know i mean if i
if it's work in progress i'll probably
be like i have to restart it but if it's
done so if i'm looking at like a thing
poster from
way back i can accept it that it's like
this is the this is the thing that
exists
so i'm not going to be like i'd really
do this differently i mean i would
tackle it again
because it'd be fun but people would be
like why are you doing this again when
you can do any other movie that you've
never done so i probably won't but
yeah one of the things about i think a
lot of people don't realize
uh this is um your early work there's a
lot of ink
on your early posters and the poster
stock itself was very thin so those
older posters become very
i know this from mix from the ones i
have they become very wavy
so i think a lot of people don't realize
that they are
they were never meant to last as long as
they're lasting
and so can you sort of address that like
the post the
the paper stock and those older ones is
not
long-lasting paper right no if this
stuff was all done is like
this is for a screening i mean just like
gig posters who would
think even in 2000 2005 that you're
going to want to have
a gig poster from like a foo fighters
concert
um and for another 30 years this is
something that you're buying at the
concert you're buying the school thing
you're
it home you're tacking it up on your
wall with pins and then you
after 10 years or whatever you move on
and so we did that with
screen printed posters i really like
this super thin newsprint stuff because
i like
kind of the immediacy of like this is
just printed for this event it's a cool
thing
and it just looked cool to me but then
everyone was like this paper is so
tissue paper thin why are you using it
so eventually i had to break away from
it
and i really missed that paper but like
you say
i open up my files and i'm like this
stuff uh it has a
it has a shelf life and so then since
then more printers are kind of like okay
we need to be considering
um the longer lifespan of these and so i
think a lot of paper companies and
printers
were a little more responsible i guess i
think it raises the prices
the cost of printing a little bit but uh
it is worth it just to try to make stuff
last a lot more archivally um
which probably isn't a word but anyway
um
that's something that we have done and
considered um i still have copies of all
that old stuff and
if you keep a ton of other posters on it
it doesn't really have waves in it you
just have to put like
50 000 other posters on it but it is
hard because especially when people say
i bought this for a lot of money and
then you're signing it and
you feel bad at things you just didn't
think about having to make something
last for like 30 years
and uh so yeah it's something that we've
tried to change and i think
hopefully we're doing a better job well
i think with the older posters
once you frame them and they're in like
a
good quality frame and it's airtight the
poster will last
much longer which leads me to like for
example
like uh you know one of your older
posters whatever it may be i know you
have them in your flat files have you
ever thought about
putting some of these in frames to sort
of help the shelf life
or do you feel that like just having a
pile of posters on it
keeps it sort of safe yeah i mean
it's really hard for me because i don't
look at these things so i would have no
problem like taking a thing poster out
or a robocop and putting tax in it and
putting my wall because i'm like
i made the poster so i can whatever i do
to it
that's that's that's the person that
made it should be able to do whatever
they want i don't
really think about it in terms of like
am i adding to the value
it is it's really difficult for me
because i'm like this is just
part of your collection of work i
actually don't mean adding the value i
mean like preserving it so you still
have a copy in 10 years
yeah yeah that's totally a good point i
mean sarah kind of said we can't
frame anything more until we have wall
space so
we just don't have you know the the
framing and
you know we're not uh we're very frugal
i won't say cheap but
we have stuff that we framed like 20
years ago so my early gig posters
and those are still hanging up in our
house and in our walls here
um so it's it's one of those things that
we just like why get something more
framed when we i don't have a single
movie poster framed if you can believe
it
i have movie posters tacked up all over
here but most of them were done by other
people
older stuff and then my movie stuff i've
seen some beautiful frame ups and i'm
always like i need to
uh do a frame up of some of my prints
you know
i would love to have the star wars
series framed and stuff
but i just you know time gets away from
you
no no i get it it's also probably
different for the person who made it
you know um so i know i get that um are
you a little bit
surprised you recently um you recently
started doing wood posters
uh or wood i don't know if the right if
it's not posters but would
prince i don't know what the right term
is are you a little bit surprised at the
success
of these or were you sort of like talk a
little bit about that
these wood posters i'll hold it up this
way
but anyway um yeah they're just uh
something that we got into just because
again it's fun you know with a lot of
things you kind of feel like
if i put out a movie poster and then a
movie poster and then the movie poster
you're you're falling into
uh for me like kind of a little bit of a
a groove
and you're you're taxing the same people
they're like i have to collect every
single one of his movie posters and so
then they're spending a lot of money and
i know just from experience on like
comics and stuff you can really be like
man i spent a lot of money
on you know scud the disposable assassin
this year i bought the entire series and
so
that really uh can take a toll on
someone
um or just to tax a person text an
audience so by switching it to like
stickers or band posters or
t-shirts or in this case wood prints
you're kind of trying to target a
different audience that might be
i don't collect any of his movie prints
but oh this is something new i'll
collect this or i'll buy one of these
just because i want to have an art piece
in my in my house and so
that was kind of the idea plus for me
you're kind of expanding your skill set
of
everything is screen printed so you know
let's try getting a laser
and starting to paint wood and and burn
through that and
and have these kind of intricate designs
that are kind of burned in with kind of
a laser that has a real nice
hand done screen printed type of
aesthetic and it doesn't look like it
came out of a computer
so um it was all just kind of these all
these different uh
angles that you're like these are all
things that appeal to me is trying
something new learning something new
appealing to a different audience
and then once you get it done you're
like okay how much should we be charging
for these because they take so long to
make
you're putting together you know this
one wood piece
you know you're sanding all the pieces
and then you're painting it and you're
lasering it
um it's not like screen printed posters
which are historically made
because they're cheap to print so it's
just like one color for a thousand
pieces of paper
and then you take those back to the
printer and you do the next color a
thousand pieces of paper
so they're more of a cheaper medium
whereas these are a little more
hand done type thing so it was just a
different it was kind of a pushing
yourself fun thing that we could
create in-house i guess yeah i'm curious
um
how long does it typically take for you
to make one of those wood
prints probably longer than it should
um are you getting are you getting
faster
i am actually yeah yeah show them
show it again okay so you basically have
these pieces of wood
you could just do one piece of wood but
i always like that kind of the
the shipyard like different pieces all
tacked together
i got a couple of pneumatic you know
finished nailers and stuff
and uh i'm just out there in our barn
and
just putting these together and sanding
them down and being like this is a lot
of fun like i could just be out there
just breathing in all this wood dust
shortening my lifespan but um it's a lot
of fun it's very relaxing so you just
start
banging out all these blanks so you're
like okay i need it this size
and i really like working with which a
lot of people hate
some of my friends are like you cannot
work with pallet wood it's so cheap
but to me i hate the idea that pallets
just get tossed you know
and it's like wood because we know
living in the northwest
i hate seeing trees just get chopped
down and that's our entire industry out
here is
let's just take down these 150 year old
trees and um
it's just hard to see so i hate seeing
pallets that just get tossed and tossed
and tossed
and so it's fun to be able to take cheap
wood and then kind of repurpose it and
use it
give it a second life that's a little
higher i don't know i don't know if
wood considers it's having itself like a
cast system you know a lifesaver
if it did they'd be like i was a palette
and now i'm an art print on someone's
wall
so you kind of uh project onto these
inanimate objects and say i you know
this is a little partnership with me
buddy
no it's actually it's actually really
cool because you are right pallet wood
is
is an afterthought and you're elevating
it to something that people are going to
frame and put on their wall
yeah yeah it's pretty fun and some of it
is actually really nice it's nice hard
wood that they want to make sure last
through this whole shipping process
you just have to make sure you're not
using this stuff that has a certain uh
coating on it that it'll actually cause
brain damage so you have to look for it
make sure it's kiln drying
dried and not like chemically dried but
anyway they've outlawed those chemicals
so they're very rare
uh completely didn't even think about
that uh you recently sold
a bunch of stickers that come with hand
bills
and i you you make it so uh i say this
is a fan
um it's hard to sometimes get the ones
that you want
uh in terms of the hand hand bills so
have you and sarah ever talked about
like selling full sets of the pros and
cons
or is it sort of like you like you want
people to sort of have to hunt
to get a full set yeah
yeah i mean it's really weird uh
being in the position i'm in where you
you kind of get a little feedback from
people that collect this stuff and then
you feel uh indebted to those people
just because they have spent money
on your stuff and you feel really
grateful for that and
early on in these pros and cons series i
was like
i'm going to sell you know i'm just
going to give these away with sticker
packs to kind of do a cool thing and
then later on i'll sell some sets
and then people would email me and said
you know i spent all this money on ebay
collecting the set you know i'm really
happy with it how do you think that look
at the frame up
and you start feeling like if i turn
around you know because they would spend
maybe three hundred dollars collecting
the whole set
and you're like i can't really turn
around and just sell it for
fifty dollars and sell all the prints it
would just make you feel like you're
kind of doing that
person a disservice and i remember those
emails so clearly and it really kind of
then
sets something in your mind you're like
okay i can't sell these as sets now
because people
are spending money in the aftermarket to
collect them and i would be
kind of just they wouldn't be very it
would kind of feel bad about themselves
that they
kind of jumped the gun and bought it and
so it just made it like okay i guess
we'll just have to work around this and
make see if we can make money just doing
the sticker packs and never selling them
as seth
so that that actually makes
um complete sense um and i get that
um i still think that you could sell
like 10 or 20 cents
on on your site at like a very limited
amount um
and make it you know where you know
you're selling because you make
different versions
yeah you can easily do like 10 of the
regular 10 of the alt
and i still think people would be okay
with it yeah yeah probably
is there anything that you wish people
knew about
the way you work or the poster
like the what goes on behind the scenes
that maybe people don't even think to
to ask about yeah
i wish they knew less actually
people like show your process of working
show you know all this sort of stuff
let's more interviews i'm like no i wish
i had no
history whatsoever and it was just a
blank slate but uh no there are certain
things i mean
i always appreciate it when people are
kind in their email sometimes we'll get
real angry ones
and i'm like this isn't we're not a
corporation we're not a company that we
have like a
hr or someone fielding them it's just
sarah and me
and so when we get real nasty emails
then sarah she responds to everything
other than like
uh personal stuff i try to respond to
but if it's poster like related that's
like how can i purchase that then she
responds to it
and if i see one that's pretty nasty
then i just like spam
because i'm like you know who can deal
with negative stuff in your life you
kind of just say
we don't have we don't have the
bandwidth for it so that's something
that i
i appreciate a lot of people do
understand is that we are just
a mom and pop shop and
it's just two of us and so we don't have
like a huge
you know so you want you want people to
kind of understand that we're just doing
this to to make a living and have fun
and we hope that people are having fun
and people are like i'm really upset
about missing that and
i'm like there's always the next one and
there's always the one after that it's
you know and there's a secondary market
which we don't necessarily encourage
people to go on but a lot of times
they're like i can't believe i wasn't
able to get this terminator print
and i'm like there's a terminator print
on ebay for 65 dollars
so it's not like well i could have made
a thousand dollars but i'm just like
it's
it's something that you're kind of like
it's just perspective so that's
something that you always appreciate and
99.9 percent of people are always super
awesome
but yeah other than that i can't think
of anything that i really wish
people knew yeah no
do you pay attention to what people are
saying on facebook in your group
or in other poster communities or do you
try to avoid
i i don't try to avoid i 100
a void i don't actually have a facebook
account so i'm like one of those people
that's like i don't have a tv
but i do have a tv i have several tvs
but um facebook i just never got into it
early on
and then i just uh sarah has one and so
she kind of keeps me in the loop but
and i don't read i have a hard time
reading instagram comments on my stuff
because i i love reading personal emails
it's awesome it's always addressed to me
but that whole
secondary culture of like um talking
about things i'm just i appreciate that
people have conversations but
it's it's weird the things that kind of
get into your mind and you're like i
really don't want to obsess about this
like i even have a hard time following
other artists on instagram
like ken taylor who i love and i'm like
if i follow his stuff i'm worried that
i'm going to be influenced by his stuff
and start copying it or
you know being accused of ripping it off
or anything like that so there's certain
people that you're just like
i appreciate them in their own realm and
i'm in my own realm and i don't
necessarily
um try to reach across i mean as a
friend obviously i try to reach across
but not necessarily
following that type of stuff or reading
comments or
i just figure like i like the idea of
kind of working within a small contained
area
and if you put it out and eventually
your sales start dropping then i'll be
like
what's happening here maybe i should pay
attention and people you go back and
realize you did something really
offensive
unintentionally but until then
i have a lot of friends like that read
stuff and they'll kind of say you know
people are really curious about this and
so
people have been really kind about that
and letting me know that i need to
address
certain things that are maybe wild
speculation and stuff so then i'll
update my website and stuff
so it's just a balance of not letting
people kind of get in your head and make
if everyone's like saying do this poster
do this poster and then you're kind of
like
you know you don't want to get let it
influence the direction that you're
going to go with your life kind of thing
but
i don't know it's weird no no i i i
completely get that
you recently sold sneakers and socks
and which again is a new direction for
you
was it something that has this been a
huge pain in the ass
or has this been something that you've
enjoyed is this like the beginning of
you selling other socks and other
sneakers
yeah well i appreciate you mentioning
that i think you're the only one that is
um it was this huge thing that i
i was getting these custom shoes printed
by vans and they were coming from
overseas and it was like a hundred
dollars a pair
and i was just like oh these are cool
like just with custom designs and then i
was like how much would it make cost to
make my own
so i researched it i found a company
that was willing to do it i got some
chest samples i was like this is awesome
and then i had them printed and i didn't
realize how much
work goes into this like apparel stuff
especially with shoes
where it's like a billion different
sizes and styles
and and then you order those and they're
like no you have to have x amount per
size ordered
and no you have to have x amount choose
total order
so i think i sold like 200 200 of
certain designs
and the minimum order was like 600 so i
i took a huge bath on those
so that's really exciting but anyway
sarah was just like usually it works in
reverse usually we have money coming in
and this time we have a lot of money
going out so
uh we're gonna have shoes for like four
days
and they haven't even they haven't even
arrived yet they're shipping they're
gonna be here at the end
at the beginning of may and so it was a
fun super fun experience and maybe when
i get the shoes in here and i'm looking
at them and
able to give them out to all the
neighborhood kids and i just see
everybody wearing them i'll be like this
is really worth it but uh
there's learning it's just a learning
thing with even with shirts we've done
shirts and
um it's really hard to store all of your
leftover shirts and you have to do all
the sizes where with prints
you can store 100 prints or 300 prints
in about this much space you know a
flat file area and so that was just
different things you know stickers were
kind of branching out and those were a
success and then shoes
i i feel like we might have seen the
last of the shoes i mean
these will come out and if people wear
them and they're clambering for more but
uh it was a it was a hard thing and the
next thing i'm looking into is i'm
looking into toys and be like what would
this cost and
you know seven hundred dollars to make
the prototype and you're like okay and
sarah's like pointing to the shoe bill
and being like no
so anyway i think that once people start
getting the shoes and they um
i think that the the shoes are something
like it's hard to sort of see it and
basically what i'm saying is i think
that you'll be able to sell the shoes
again especially after people are
wearing them
and they might be like oh those are cool
where'd you get them you know
um so i wouldn't say you you know it's
like a long haul in terms of the
business
and with toys you might want to partner
with another company
uh than doing it yourself because that's
a whole different thing
right right yeah yeah i i hope you're
right
yeah shoes and then with the toys i'm
sure you're right it is one of those
things that you just have to find the
right opportunity
and i have a hard time just with
bandwidth i kind of want to keep
everything in house and have
you know sarah and the kids working on
it but i do need to partner more with
other places and be like okay you guys
even with this gray matter thing they're
actually handling uh
uh the halloween release they're
shipping 100 of the posters which is the
first for me
i've always sold my own copies
separately and now they're selling all
the copies
and that was just because we came off
this terminator thing sarah was working
a ton
on that and i thought well what can i do
to make
her life our lives a little easier and
so we're gonna try it you'll see how it
goes you take a little bit of a
you know it's more of a partnership so
you're not just like a soul person
um but uh we'll see it's something that
we're trying this new and i think
michael's a good guy a gray matter
that's a great company so
it might be a new trend we'll see we
like having that personal contact with
with people buying from us because
you're kind of developing fun
relationships and it's not just this
transaction type thing so does that mean
you're not going to sell
aps does that mean or that's a down the
road kind of a thing
it's a down the road thing just because
we're
i don't even know how many aps will get
just because they're doing them all
there so if he's selling them i don't
feel like they're necessarily
aps because they'll be selling them so i
don't even know we're kind of discussing
that right now but
it will be something if ever it won't be
for years
i would assume that we would sell any of
our copies just because
it that's kind of the agreement we
reached is that they would handle it and
so
it'll be fun and i think he'll he'll do
a good job and make him available to the
same people that i would make them
available to
and i hope it's a real positive
experience for everybody
i also think there's a yeah after
terminator and all the work but anyway i
know we're running very long so i have
like a few last things then we'll
leave it go um what do i need to do to
get you to do a galaxy quest poster
yeah let's make it happen um
it's just a matter of uh having the uh
you know all the things lining up you
know making sure
you know if they're like galaxy quest
and we have you know tim allen and
sigourney weaver
are the rights that we have and then
you're kind of like can i make a galaxy
quest poster with just
those two people though that's that's
the challenges that you face
and so if somebody comes and says we're
doing a promotional screening we have
all these people in attendance the
directors on board they're going to sign
away
and get all the cash to approve this
small run then i'm like let's do that
that
sounds awesome so i'm always up for that
it's just a matter of lining it up so
you're doing something
because like my time and everybody's
time is so limited that you're like
i don't want to do a galaxy quest now
that's like with two like this
and then 10 years from now someone comes
along and says i have all like this and
you're like great now i have to do it
over again and do a better job
so you try to kind of set it up and be
like this is probably the only halloween
poster
i'll ever do i'm not gonna come back and
be like now we got the rights to
three more people we can do another one
like it this is probably it there's so
many posters out there why do one
twice how much stuff do you have behind
the scenes right now
that um you're working on that you know
for example like whether it be band
posters or art posters or movie posters
that you sort of are close to completion
on
or like that you're working on right now
or is it not that many
not that many just because it takes a
certain amount of time
to do something that you're like okay
i'm working on i'm working out i'm done
working on it and then sarah's like
not sarah but you know house bills and
stuff necessitate that you're like okay
now we have to sell this
so we make you know it's like your
paycheck that you've been working for
for
three weeks and so we can't just afford
to put it on layaway unless it's
something that they're like
hold the brakes on that so um usually i
put stuff out pretty soon after i get it
completed
but there's a few projects that i'm
talking with there's all these galleries
that we're talking with
um that we have buddies at that they're
saying let's do this let's do this and
so you have projects that are kind of in
your mind that you're
you know working on like just mentally
and saying okay now i have a two week
block i'm gonna do this
and then we'll get it done so i would
say at any given time i have five to ten
uh avenues where people are saying do
this comic book cover do this thing
and you're just thinking about it and
thinking what would i do what would i do
but when the actual like pen to paper
process comes then it turns around
pretty quickly and then you do it and
hopefully it comes out in a relatively
reasonable time um you've done a number
of marvel properties
uh a number of marvel posters do you
think that
uh you'll be doing more of those or is
it sort of
working with marvel while awesome is
just so challenging
because of how many back and forth it is
yeah
i hope you i hope to do all of them just
because i love those movies my kids love
those movies
and so it kind of drives me crazy that
i've done like an iron man 2 poster and
you know some of the avengers post some
of the captain you're like you need to
really
just the ocd nature of it you got to
have the whole series you know it would
be like doing a two towers poster
and not either one of the lord of the
rings stuff so
um i would love to do them all it's just
a matter of lining it all up and
and being like okay let's do this let's
tackle this and so
there there are opportunities i think on
the horizon for that to start happening
again where we can do it
it's just been making it line up and um
so we'll see that's that's the hope
though is that we can definitely at
least for this whole block
rounding it all out and i don't know if
it continues on into uh
eternals and the era that's to come
but at least getting the ones done that
have come out so far was such a perfect
series you're like this would be
awesome to tackle any of those so i
think it's my last thing
um uh i you know i love your sean of the
dead poster
so i'm wondering what what we need to do
to get hot fuzz
or a tornado trilogy poster you know um
or
at world's end like what do we need to
do to make these posters happen
right yeah those are those are awesome
but i love that whole series so
i think it's just a matter of those
things be perfect for like screenings
you have a screening get every right and
then all of a sudden you have
him signing off and stuff and then that
would be that would be amazing because
i've heard stories about like nick frost
is like oh i have the space
poster you did hanging in my bathroom
and i'm like that's awesome that's a
real compliment
so uh it'll be awesome to tackle any of
those and get that whole thing
rounded out so make it happen